the ball was up for grabs and maryland  comes up with it a beautiful dish and  wow what a finish that is a poster man  oh man  windler tried to get in there those were  smith's first points in 21 minutes  of playing time aiella numbers  sticks with some big bark  because of that young had to kick it out  now spencer's kicking the ball  up ahead  [Applause]  guess who did not miss it jalen smith  there's a foul as well wiggins the  rebound for the turfs  smith  [Applause]  he's had to work awfully hard to get  free of morsell long pass ahead smith  one on the floor  the hammer and the foul oh my goodness  jalen smith throwing it down in  transition